- Give it up for Nick Offerman!
(ukulele playing)
- ♪ Holidays on the Kelly Clarkson show ♪
(crowd cheering)
♪ Here in the San Fernando
well where the rain does snow ♪
♪ I'd like to wrestle my
wife under the mistletoe ♪
♪ But I'll leave it at that,
'cause this is a family show ♪
- I love it!
I love this!
- Thank you.
- Wait, did you- say hello!
- Hello!
- [Clarkson] Did you make that,
is that one of the things you've made?
- I did make this ukulele.
- [Clarkson] What?
- It's garbage, actually.
(crowd laughs)
If you look up close.
But it sounds like a ukulele.
- [Clarkson] I was gonna
say it sounds great, yeah.
- Did you see "The Beatles: Get Back"?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- That was kind of based
on me and my song writing.
(crowd and Clarkson laughing)
- The similarities are just uncanny.
So wait, what else have you made recently?
- What I made is you look fantastic.
- Oh thank you!
(crowd cheering)
It's so nice to be here for the holidays.
- We love Christmas.
We were trying to go big for Christmas.
I'm Texan, we don't go small ever.
But I love that you make
things, I think it's so cool.
And I don't know like a lot of people
that really do that in general anymore.
I think that's so cool.
- I think it's really healthy.
I was brought up in a family
of people who make things
and Megan is amazing.
Just a couple of days ago,
she made me the most amazing pecan pie.
- [Clarkson] I love pecan pie.
- I mean, I can't wait.
There's still a couple of pieces left.
So if we can keep things moving.
- So that was rude, you didn't bring any.
(crowd laughing)
- No I didn't.
- Fine, fine.
- And I wanna get home.
- Well you said before that you and Megan,
y'all make each other gifts, right?
- That's right.
- So like what?
Like what are some examples?
- Well, I love making her stuff.
I mean, I make her furniture and you know,
other things out of wood and sometimes,
we've been together 21 years-
- Wow, that's amazing.
(crowd cheering)
- If I come up short, 'cause I like to do
traditional anniversary gifts and stuff,
but sometimes, you know that list
where it's like, your five is copper.
- Or the wood is one.
- Yeah, so one year was willow.
So I made her a little
elf spoon out of willow,
out of the wood willow
and that went over big.
And so then a few times, if
I don't have a good idea,
then I've made her a fork and a knife.
(crowd laughing)
- You lean back into the cutlery.
- Yeah, and there's a
tea cup and a saucer.
So I think eventually, you know,
as long as I don't get
kicked out of the house,
she'll eventually have a full dinner set.
- (laughing) I love her elves, I love it.
Wait, so you made Amy Poehler,
is it correct that it
was a paddle out of doors
and it was doors from the
"Parks and Rec" set, right?
- Yeah.
- How did you do that?
- When the show finished,
the entire bullpen
of that great set for "Parks and Rec',
all the trim was red oak that actually
had come from Indiana to California.
- I know, but they let you have it?
- Well, no, here's the thing.
(crowd laughing)
- Oh.
- And this is a real beef I have
with the corporate side of our business,
is that because of liability,
you're not supposed to take
anything out of the dumpster.
Like wood.
- But it's wasteful.
- It's super wasteful.
So I've mentioned when they struck the set
for "Parks and Rec', I
said to the guy driving
the truck to the landfill,
if you happen to hit a
speed bump near my shop
and some of this red oak
falls onto the sidewalk,
(crowd laughing)
I would love to turn it into canoe paddles
to give to the cast and the producers.
- Which is so cool.
- So, yeah, I mean-
(crowd cheering)
- I'm grateful that that
driver was somewhat reckless.
(crowd laughing)
- Yeah, that's unfortunate.
But what kind of music do you listen to
whenever you're making stuff?
- In the shop, the wood
shop is a great place
to play music because you know,
you're often sanding a table like this,
or painting varnish, you know,
jobs that require some meditative moments.
So the first music I listened to was
in my dad's basement shop.
And I remember in the winter,
he'd have the wood stove going.
And there was a radio station
out of Chicago called WJJD.
And they would play like The
Mills Brothers and Tommy Dorsey
and Rosemary Clooney, Ella Fitzgerald,
sort of big band swing, jazz era.
So that always makes me
feel really nostalgic.
And like when I hear The Mills Brothers,
I get the smell of varnish.
- Oh I love that nostalgia,
like it comes with memories, music.
I love that.
- But yeah, we listened
to all kinds of stuff.
- I do that when I quilt.
I put vinyl on whenever I
quilt, that's my big thing.
I go to a classic
superstar like Carole King,
like that's a good one.
- Totally, or early Neil Young.
- Yeah, Neil Young, great.
- Or any of those Laurel Canyon gang,
Crosby, Stills, Nash.
- It's like a total party happening
while you're making stuff.
(crowd cheering)
The new book is called, I love the title,
"Where the Deer and the Antelope Play",
and then there's more
words, I said it before,
but what's it about,
like what inspired this?
I love this.
- Well, it's about our
relationship with nature.
You know, I love to read
certain agrarian writers,
which is a fancy word for good farmers.
People who grow a crop or
livestock with an eye towards
how can we raise cattle
on this land in a way
that we can keep doing
it that will sustain
the nature on this land.
And when I was reading,
I was like, oh yeah,
I'm really guilty, as most of us are
with being lazily ignorant to like,
who grows our food and
where does it come from?
And are we taking care of the land?
- And what's being sprayed on it?
- Yeah, exactly.
And so with a sense of humor,
I travel around, do a few different trips,
and, you know, talk about our relationship
with nature in this book.
- [Clarkson] I love that.
Well, and you grew up in nature,
you grew up on a farm, right?
- In a farm family, yeah, in
Illinois working for my family.
- Did you have like all
those jobs, like my daughter,
she got excited, she came home
from our ranch in Montana,
and apparently one of her jobs,
well her job was literally
mucking the stalls.
So she just was shoveling
horse poop and she loved it.
- Well, that's the thing,
that was my first job,
was shoveling out the pig waste.
- Okay, this is the thing
we give children. (laughing)
I love it.
- That's the thing.
- Her arms were killing her, she was like-
- It's work that needs doing,
but you can't really break anything,
like you can't screw it up.
- Yeah, I think it's really good for kids
to grow up doing stuff like that.
But did you ever see, you know,
I know you took a road
trip, you and Megan,
so did y'all ever see any like
deer or antelope on the range?
- We did actually, yeah.
I mean, in parts of Texas and Arizona,
while I was out hiking,
we would run into both deer and antelope.
They didn't seem super playful,
they were more businesslike.
- Yeah, like get away.
- They were looking for food.
- So whose idea it was
for y'all to travel,
because you traveled
around in an Airstream,
which I love an Airstream by the way.
- Oh man, they're so groovy.
Megan is the curator of
all things in our house.
Like if work needs doing
that requires tools,
then it's in my wheel house.
Otherwise, if it's picking
anything with taste or culture,
we're like, honey, please tell me
what movie we're gonna see.
So it was her idea to go
see our families in Oklahoma
and Illinois for Thanksgiving last year.
So we went, we thought
we were gonna go buy
one of those Sprinter vans
that's like a little Airstream.
And we ended up leaving
with the biggest Airstream
they had for sale.
- Oh my God, we're the same.
And then did you get out
there and have any issues?
'Cause that's the thing, that
you think this is so fun.
And then you get out there,
and you're like, oh no.
(crowd laughing)
Something goes wrong,
did anything go wrong?
- Not completely wrong.
But like, I was busy
actually shooting a season
of "Making It" with Amy Poehler
while we were about to leave on this trip.
So I didn't have time to sort of-
- All I'm hearing are
excuses right now. (laughing)
- Okay, here comes some more.
So I was like, I've handled
equipment my whole life,
so I'm sure I'll figure it out as we go.
But the very first night we
got to the place too late,
so they wouldn't let us in.
They made us stay in a parking lot.
And I wasn't familiar, you've
got an electrical system,
you got plumbing, you got septic tanks,
you got propane, all
kinds of stuff going on.
And I hadn't had the time
to figure it all out yet.
So the first night we spent
freezing our butts off.
Like we couldn't turn the heat on
because we didn't have electricity.
There's nothing to plug into.
So very quickly I learned how
to get on top of those systems,
and fortunately, we're still married.
(crowd laughing)
- I was going to say, did you learn that
because of your desire
or her annoyance at you
not knowing? (laughing)
- The two are not unconnected.
(crowd laughing)
- I love that, I love that moment.
I can just see both of
you, like this is so great.
This is a time together.
You're like freezing in it.
So wait in the book you
revealed that you and your wife
both have a connection to Rob Lowe.
And I know that connection,
but everyone else doesn't, so explain.
- Well, you know, when you get together
with another actor and this is true,
and this is my whole life,
when you start dating someone,
one of the things you do, you
have an awareness of like,
oh, by the way, I was in
a play with this person
or you like, you figure out
who you've both kissed or like-
- This is a conversation?
- Yeah, it's a thing so
that, you know, I mean,
it's true of any new
relationship where it's-
- Not me, I don't wanna know any past.
(crowd laughing)
- But eventually you learn about
each other's significant others.
And in this case, because
he's a marquee name,
it came up at some point that Megan,
in the movie "About Last Night",
had had this crazy throat
kissing scene with Rob Lowe,
where she plays this floozy,
like trying to distract
him from Demi Moore.
And they have this crazy
French kissing scene.
And at some point I randomly saw it.
We were at a hotel and
it happened to be on TV.
And it was so traumatic where I was like-
(crowd laughing)
- What are you doing!
- I mean, it was 15 years
later, but I said, honey,
you clearly are in love with Rob Lowe.
(Clarkson and crowd laughing)
This is gonna be a situation between us.
And so it always kind of stuck with me.
But then until some years
later on "Parks and Recreation"
in an episode where I think
Rob Lowe's character finds out
that it's Ron Swanson's birthday
and he ends up kissing me on
the mouth in this episode.
- Both been there.
- At which point I was
like, okay, honey, I get it.
(Clarkson and crowd laughing)
- It's even.
- Everything's cool, everything's fine.
And now, if you step back
a little ways and squint,
you could say that we've had a threesome.
(Clarkson laughing)
That's how it is in Hollywood.
- That's what your book
should have been called.
(laughing)
Our threesome with Rob Lowe. (laughing)
That's amazing, I love that.
I don't know if I'd
wanna know all of that.
Not that it bothers me, I just mean like
you can't help your past,
so why talk about it?
- It is weird, and especially
if your wife is a gorgeous,
you know, star they keep coming
out where you'll be watching
a show and she'll be like, oh, actually,
I was engaged to this guy,
you know, and you're like.
- Oh my God.
And you're like, no, it's fine.
- It's fine, honey.
- (laughing) That's amazing.
Well, Nick's book is called
"Where the Deer and the Antelope Play:
the Pastoral Observations
of One Ignorant American
Who Loves to Walk Outside."
It's out now, I cannot wait to read it.
I love you so much.
You're literally one of my
favorite people on the show.
Oh, thank you so much.